this is a Fox News Alert AP reporting
that former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie will be dropping out of the
Republican primary race and we'll bring
you more on that when it happens but
first the hunter Biden circus rolling
into Washington today in a political
stunt so obviously coordinated by the
Democrats Hunter crashing his own
contempt house hearing one month after
defying a congressional subpoena Hunter
sitting front row with his own backpack
of characters guy on the left his bong
ripping sugar brother and on the right
his lawyer Abby LOL the smug first son
answering no questions but Republican
lawmakers giving him an
earful you are the epitome of white
privilege what are you afraid of you
have no balls if the gentle lady wants
to hear from Hunter Biden we can hear
from him right now Mr chairman let's
take a vote and hear from Hunter Biden
what are you allow to speak hold on hold
on order order I think that uh that
Hunter Biden should be arrested right
here right now and go straight to jail
excuse me Hunter apparently you're
afraid of my
words here
goes eventually Hunter got bored of his
own stunt and stormed out of the hearing
a little early but he couldn't escape
these questions listen what kind of
crack do you normally smoke Mr Biden Mr
Biden why did you put your dad on
speaker phone with your business
partners if he had no involvement in
your
business do you have a dad dides he call
you yes answer the phone yes okay but
why did you need to talk to him during
business meetings if he had nothing to
do with your
business house committee approving
contemp resolution against Hunter Biden
and the White House is literally just
laughing it off
listen Hunter Biden on Capitol Hill
today how big of a headache is that for
you H Biden is a private citizen he is
not a member of the White House as you
know and I just don't have anything else
to share but the last time he was on the
hill he said the president was certainly
familiar with what his son was going to
say I did say that and here and what I'm
saying that President Biden does not
help him with his business deals but he
does help him skirt Congressional subis
that is not even true that that is a
jump that
is that is incredibly disingenuous in
that
question all right so judge Janine this
is obviously a well
orchestrated you call it a stunt Call It
Whatever It Is by The Lawyers by the
sugar brother do you think this is an
effective strategy for Hunter Biden
legally what do you think he won by that
I mean really it was a stunt no
different than the stunt that that was
that that occurred when he appeared on
the Senate side the day he was supposed
to appear before Congress look I don't
know if he was saying I'm not afraid of
you he sat in the front row you're not
going to intimidate me but uh I guess I
am afraid of meeting behind closed doors
with you which is a you know illegal
subpoena and the amazing part of it is
that this guy uh is saying that I want
to dictate the conditions of the
subpoena this is a legally drafted
subpoena they met today they have agreed
that they're going to enforce the
subpoena and now what they want to do is
they need the Full House to vote on it
now what is amazing if you want to make
a comparison Donald Trump Jr testified
five or six times in closed door
hearings be intelligence Community uh uh
committee
uh uh oversight five or six times and
the truth is that when you appear before
a committee behind closed doors they
have real lawyers real investigators who
ask you real questions and they get to
the heart of the issue this claim that I
want to testify in public because if I
don't they'll change my words number one
you can get the transcript of the words
in be behind closed doors and number two
it's nothing but a showtime for congress
people to get out there and try to get a
bite that they can get on the news now
Jamie Rasin has always been a proponent
of having these Congress people testify
behind closed doors and then they come
out before the Congress in the open and
all of a sudden they don't want that to
happen here and let me just say one more
thing about this uh they should hold
them in contempt the only question is
whether or not the justice department
will follow through now let me tell you
why this is different than uh uh Nao and
Bannon they claimed executive privilege
all right whether or not that was
legitimate or not there was some claim a
possible legitimate claim this guy is
like I'm not appearing before you I'm
going to give the middle finger to you
and the American people and um you know
don't ask me to do this now also the
White House in terms of how they handled
his his
paintings the guy who owned the gallery
do you remember we were all told
Hunter's not going to know who bought it
nobody's going to know who bought it
what the disclosures of the names were
what the conditions were it's all going
to be anonymous the guy who ran the
gallery apparently went in and testified
and said the White House never called me
and said I couldn't talk about it or he
couldn't mention it to Hunter it was all
a lie it was all a bunch of donors uh
Jessica the guy knows he's going to get
a pardon one way or the other so this is
just what just a
charade I don't know anything about the
one way or the other because his father
has been inconsistent that he is not
going to Pardon him so you think if
Donald Trump going to Pardon you think a
politician would never be inconsistent
uh I think it could happen I do not
think that it will happen in this case I
think that this is something Joe Biden
feels strongly about and I don't think
it would be something that would
completely undermine what he had been
talking about for years so you're saying
if Donald Trump wins the election and in
the lame duck session Joe Zone on the
way out he doesn't pardon Hunter Biden
that's that's what the man has said okay
we'll see if that happen okay
um so I had a little bit of a different
viewpoint on today's proceedings than
judge Janine which has happened to us
before um the Republicans came off as
completely
unprepared to even deviate one sentence
or one word from their prepared talking
points so James comr is on video he was
giving an interview um on to Benny
Johnson and was talking about when
people come before the committee and he
made it clear as he did to Hunter Biden
that you can do that behind closed doors
have a deposition like Devon Archer did
uh not in public or you can come out in
public and do it and that's what Hunter
Biden had opted to do and then comr
flipped out and he tried to take it back
so today's hearing
spring what no that was before the quote
stunt of last month he was supposed to
be able to do it publicly and what
Hunter Biden didn't want was for the
Republicans to continue to twist his
words or to do what they did to Devon
Archer who testified the exact opposite
of what Republicans said in public
anyway it you know as well as anyone the
power of Television right you walk out
from a a closed door deposition and you
say like Jim Jordan did Devon Archer uh
implicated Joe Biden in this big
corruption ring and then guess what the
transcript doesn't add up to that at all
Deon Archer completely undermined the
Republicans but it's out there and there
are millions of people that believe it
they were leg subpoena he doesn't get
that I want to talk about legitimate
subp there were three incredibly
embarrassing moments for Republicans or
my top three Nancy mace in general just
embarrassing screaming about white
privilege saying he's afraid of me he
showed up he's sitting there swear him
in let him talk then people like Scott
Perry uh Jim Jordan people who are in
the midst of defying subpoenas
themselves just sitting there railing
about how important it is and then you
said Hunter Biden got bored and he left
he intentionally embarrassed margorie
Taylor green who held up again another
poster of his genitals the woman is obs
obsessed with it okay that's good that's
three right I think you said you're
going to name three we finished with
that Greg Gutfeld yeah I mean people are
calling it a circus but if it's a circus
the ring leader is Joe Biden because if
he had not have run all of these Shady
deals by Hunter Biden to pad his dad's
life of luxury wouldn't have come to
light fact is Hunter in his defense was
just doing his job it's a corrupt money
laundering influence pedaling job but he
assumed would continue under the radar
but no more you know Jesse it's like as
if you buried a body in your backyard
and you think you're safe and then your
wife comes in and says honey let's have
a swimming pool I got an excavation
company to come in and dig out the pool
that's what happened to Hunter and it
turns out as as the judge said the White
House was lying about this stuff they
were covering up for basically what was
M money laundering that's what this is
the fact is you know you money the art
world is one of the chief places right
for money laundering it's not just waste
management although when you look at
Hunter paintings that is Waste
Management there are two laughable parts
to this
one Defenders of Hunter Biden and
especially Joe Biden will say there's no
evidence of cash changing hands from say
like Lisa
naftali and Joe Biden right but that's
idiotic do you know how money laundering
actually works it's called money
laundering for a reason the money isn't
a direct exchange it's through a scam
company it's through import export
businesses and waste management and
really shoddy artwork the second part is
how pathetic the media is for avoiding
this story which has sex drugs
Corruption of the highest order fraud
laundering sex trafficking illegal gun
use racism let's not forget the texts
and video evidence of some of the most
explicit examples and they prefer to
chase Donald Trump Jr over some cursory
meeting with somebody he barely knows
think about this if any if this were
Donald Trump Jr they'd have to pump you
know Morning Joe full of volum and give
the give the view a case of horse
tranquilizers Dana P well I think first
of all he is the very definition of
contempt of congress right so at every
turn so then the Congress has to make a
decision I think that one of the reasons
they did that is we know that they're
working on a documentary about Hunter
Biden's life and times and so this is
great new footage right because if you
like the adage of like he fights well at
least he's trying he's doing something
he couldn't resist though I'm sure the
lawyer said we're going to handle the
questions don't say anything but he has
he can't help himself and responds to
Hillary vau saying you're very dangerous
have you met Hillary vau like she's a
great report reporter she is not
dangerous what's dangerous is Hunter
Biden talking what I loved about the
moment though was that you had finally
members of Congress who were not
completely scripted by staff have to
think on their feet have to decide what
they could say without actually having
to you know look at all of their notes
and read you know added the Taylor Swift
lyrics songs into the things which are
so annoying it was like watching The
Real Housewives of the representative
House of Representatives because they we
obviously and the Democrats knew what
was happening and I wonder what if they
what if the Republicans had said fine
sit down calls Bluff and said we'll call
a recess we'll be right back go get your
ducks in a row and then come back like
that would have been also and just hold
up a bank record said well okay well
where did this money come from and just
and make him sit there chines connected
compan right exactly all right Jessica
we've heard quite
enough quite enough and by the way if
Emma wants a swimming pool we do it
above ground that's why we don't go
under with the bodies ah very clever hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else